what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to talk for a second about how the
eternals movie can introduce galactus
into the mcu right so right off the bat
i was going through the comments of the
previous video that i did and you guys
absolutely nailed what the plot of
eternals is most likely going to be
right now here's the funny thing about
that though that was only a new instance
right for years and years and years and
years marvel never explained how
celestials were born right we simply
just knew that they existed and that was
basically it we were kind of left to our
own devices to believe that the
celestial population existed as an
absolute number in any one particular
universe and because they were cosmic
entities they were akin to like eternity
infinity and those guys in the sense
that if the universe dies and is reborn
then much like those cosmic entities
will manifest the celestials will be the
same way they'll manifest as like an
absolute number and that'll basically be
it even the origin of the celestials
themselves before the events of
ultimates was a little ambiguous right
you had different origins from different
people right some saying the celestials
created the multiverse others saying
celestials were just a super advanced
race that achieved incredible power and
then just became the celestials again it
was kind of all over the place but the
funny thing about this is that the the
notion of the celestials in terms of how
they procreate was actually given to us
in a story called earth x which we
actually covered over comics explained
probably about three years ago and
people keep asking me to do the
follow-up series universe x and paradise
x and i probably will but the important
thing here is that the celestials
themselves basically procreate by
planting their seed their essence more
or less in a planet quite literally
celestials bang plants so the idea
behind this is that because these worlds
are capable of supporting life it's like
a woman carrying a baby around right she
has to consume nutrients in order to
feed the baby so the baby can grow and
so on and so forth celestial eggs work
the same way they get put inside the
core of a planet where it feeds not
really on the entire life energy of that
planet otherwise it would kill
everything but it feeds slowly on the
life energy of that planet so that life
can still grow and sustain itself and
then when the celestial is ready to be
born it basically emerges from the
planet's core and destroys it in the
process basically killing everybody on
that world now here's where galactus
comes into play in the original earth x
story when that origin of the celestials
was given to us that was simply just
kind of a one-off alternate reality and
that what ended up happening is that in
shield issue number four by jonathan
hickman we basically got this concept
from earth x which was carried over into
the main marvel universe and the rest of
the multiverse and being presented to us
as an absolute rule in terms of how
celestials procreate the only caveat to
that is that in shield number four you
got something called the celestial
madonna which was basically a woman or a
celestial that was pregnant with a
celestial and that's not how it normally
works it was considered a variant so not
really a traditional celestial born in
the traditional way and so the role that
galactus plays in relation to this at
least according to earth x and now as
it's established in the rest of marvel
comics across the multiverse is that if
the celestials basically procreate by
putting their life seeds in a planet
then galactus purpose is to travel
around the universe and basically
consume life-sustaining worlds thereby
keeping the celestial population in
check because if galactus didn't exist
then celestials would basically just
overpopulate a universe they would be
like humanity on earth right just
procreating with reckless abandon and
then leading to overpopulation problems
and so that's that's the role he plays
there now this is a cool thing because
the question you guys are most likely
asking yourself is if galactus actually
exists in the mcu already why haven't we
seen him yet well the easiest answer is
because the universe is a big place
it's a very big place right i mean if i
asked you right now what's going on in
jamaica you couldn't tell me right and
that's just earth that's not even the
universe right like what's going on in
the dark matter space of the universe
where we can't really observe anything
you can't you can't give me the answer
to that question right because you don't
know and that's the way it is with the
mcu right like there are huge portions
like right now everything you've seen in
the mcu has largely been relegated to
the milky way galaxy and maybe a couple
other places like the larger magellanic
cloud where the creek come from from the
planet holla and so on and so forth but
we haven't even really seen their home
world in its full entirety yet we simply
just know that it's there and so because
of that we've only really really looked
at like a very small portion of the
marvel cinematic universe on a universal
scale galactus could very well be out
there somewhere just consuming worlds
and that's it but the great way that
this could happen in eternals is it's a
throwaway line it's just a small little
thing now the funny thing here is that
looking at the trailers like dane
whitman's character seems to more or
less be the stand-in for us for why it
is the eternals haven't gotten involved
with anything right that's what he asked
in the second trailer why didn't you
ever stop any of the wars or why didn't
you stop thanos the sin of titan why
didn't you stop him from like blinking
out half the life of the universe where
have you been at all this time and the
answer that he was given was we were
told not to by the celestials and that
was basically it right so he kind of
seems to be the stand-in for us and it's
entirely possible that when the
emergence is explained right when that
scene comes along in the movie where
it's like we've got seven days until the
emergence and it's like well what the
hell is the emergence there's a
celestial's gonna be born in earth then
that could probably lead into a second
question which is is that how celestials
are born and the answer is yes and then
it's a third question wouldn't the
celestials just overrun the entire
universe is there nothing keeping them
in check and that's when you get the
answer well that's what galactus does
done like that's it that's that's that's
all you get right and it'd be just a
super easy way to throw his character in
the universe exists in a delicate
balance the celestials procreate by
depositing their eggs into a world and
when the egg is ready and it just dates
into a full celestial it's born
destroying the world in the process but
in order to keep the celestial
population in check galactus travels
around the universe and consumes
life-sustaining worlds thereby removing
or minimizing the amount of worlds that
celestials can deposit their eggs in so
they don't run amuck across the whole
universe now the question to ask here is
has there ever been an instance where
celestials have basically procreated and
dominated an entire universe because
galactus was destroyed or galactus
didn't exist in that universe whatever
the case is and the answer to that
question is yes that was in jonathan
hickman's fantastic four and they were
called the mad celestials so the whole
idea behind this is that in this
alternate reality which is really more
of a kind of behind the scenes
explanation which is really alluded to
us more than anything else that in an
alternate reality the celestials in that
universe had seemingly destroyed any
competition anybody who could stop them
right so eternity infinity galactus
probably different things like that
which on the surface a celestial by
themselves wouldn't be able to do that
one of the things that mad celestials
did is they actually coalesce their
energies into a massive singular
celestial which was wildly powerful
seemingly on a universal scale the
important thing here is that seemingly
in that universe those celestials
basically spread throughout all of
existence and that basically led to them
conquering the entirety of that universe
and then forcing the universe's denizens
to worship them they kind of became mad
gods that's what you want to call them
so that precedent does exist we've only
seen it once and it's only been alluded
to but the possibility is there so
that's how you could get galactus in the
marvel cinematic universe i know a lot
of people really love the theory that
thanos created galactus to basically
keep the idea going that the universe's
population would stay at a smaller
number than it was in order to ensure
that overpopulation doesn't become an
issue which is a great idea because
thanos's motivation outside of that was
kind of dumb when it came to infinity
war and avengers in-game as much as i
loved those movies thanos was an idiot
because wiping out half the life the
universe is nice but in like a thousand
years it'll be right back where it was
before right so the thing here is that
this is a great way to introduce
galactus into the mcu not to really give
us a full-on display of what he's
capable of not to really give us the
totality of what it is that he can do to
not give us like a depiction of him or
the silver surfer or anybody like that
but to somebody just tell us as the
audience galactus exists and he's been
here this entire time now whether or not
we'll get the origin of galactus from
the old thor comics i don't really know
i mean the original galactus can be done
in any number of different ways and
honestly i don't really care how he got
there i just hope that he's there
that's all i really care about but
nonetheless it's a great way to
introduce the character into the marvel
cinematic universe with a really simple
put together process that's easy to
understand super simple to digest and
then leaves us wanting more because if
we end up finding out that galactus does
exist by way of the eternals film we're
going to want to see him but we're going
to want to see galactus right this just
giant guy this giant purple guy with a
helmet and how he looks is relative to
the people who were looking at him like
i i would love that right i would
absolutely love that concept i know you
guys would too especially the silver
surfer uh i'm gonna audition for the
voice over gig with silver surfer if
that ever happens i don't think i'll
ever get it i don't know it's worth a
shot but like i want to audition for it
i feel like i'd have a voice for a good
silver surfer but nonetheless guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end because
i'm kind of rambling at this point thank
you guys for watching let me know how
excited you are to see galactus in the
mcu and i will catch you all later
peace